Glaubenskriege müssen nicht notgedrungen
blutig sein verbissen sind sie allemal
den Beweis dafür liefert der aktuelle
Streit um eine Laufzeitverlängerung der
letzten verbliebenen Atomkraftwerke
diese Woche hat Robert Habeck
entschieden zwei AKW zum Jahresende noch
nicht so ganz in die Mottenkiste zu
werfen Galgenfrist dreieinhalb Monate
und damit dreieinhalb Monate länger eine
leidenschaftliche Kontroverse
Stresstest atomkraft ja bitte jetzt in
der Phönix Runde
herzlich Willkommen bei uns meine Gäste
dieser badung ist bei uns von Bündnis 90
die Grünen Bundestagsabgeordnete und sie
sind ob Frau ihrer Fraktion im Ausschuss
für Klimaschutz und Energie
Andreas Jürgen ist von der
cdu/csu-bundestagsfraktion
Klima und energiepolitischer Sprecher
dort und auch gleichzeitig
stellvertretender Parteivorsitzender der
CDU Daniel Wetzel ist
Wirtschaftsredakteur in den Zeitungen
und bei den Zeitungen Welt und Welt am
Sonntag und Martin Kaiser
Geschäftsführer von Queen peace
Deutschland
die
Atomkraftwerke die bleiben ja nicht als
streckbetrieb ab Januar Netz wie von den
Netzbetreibern gefordert wurde sondern
als sogenannte Notfall Reserve wir reden
auch noch drüber ob das so sinnvoll ist
sie nur als Notfallreserve da
bereitzustellen das heißt Atomstrom nur
im äußersten Notfall in die Netze sollte
denn mit dieser Entscheidung wie gesagt
über die Sinnhaftigkeit reden wir gleich
noch sollte da vor allen Dingen die doch
ziemlich murrende grüne Basis
beschwichtigt werden also ganz klar es
ist zwar schwierig für mich zu sehen
dass ein
notatomstrombetrieb wenn es auch nur für
dreieinhalb Monate ist im Raum steht auf
der anderen Seite wir brauchen Prozess
der Entscheidungsfindung und den hatte
habe ich vorgelegt wir werden auf
Grundlage der Fakten im Dezember
entscheiden was wir tun werden aus
meiner Sicht gibt es bisher keine
Evidenzen das Atomkraft uns wirklich
hilft in der Situation da kann man
glaube ich in der Diskussion noch aber
das ist jetzt das Verfahren wir werden
als Parlament natürlich ein genaues Auge
drauf haben auf das Monitoring und vor
allem dass wir alles tun um diesen
Notfall auch zu vermeiden jung aus der
Union da tönt ja ein mehrstimmiger Chor
da das geht vom streckbetrieb also dem
vollständigen optimalen Verbrauch und
Ausnutzen der Brennstäbe bis hin zu
einer
Laufzeitverlängerung noch über mehrere
Jahre ist da alles im Angebot was ist
denn ihre Strategie wir haben eine ganz
klare und ganz gemeinsame Haltung und
die heißt es muss jetzt in dieser Krise
um ein Notstand abzuwenden um übrigens
auch nicht einseitig auf klimaschädliche
Kohle zu setzen müssen alle Kapazitäten
genutzt werden und es deckt sich eins zu
eins mit dem sie uns schon zitiert was
die Übertragungsnetzbetreiber sagen sein
die ausdrücklich eines gesündlich gesagt
sie sagen es in ihrer Empfehlung und
Robert habe kennt sich aber nicht dran
sondern da wird jetzt dieser
stottermodus vorgeschlagen da weiß man
gar nicht ob das definiert kann man die
so schnell hoch und runter fahren da
soll er eine Vorbereitung damit
getroffen werden auf lagen die können
sich kurzfristig einstellen wir wissen
ja nicht über eine Woche im Voraus wann
es besonders kalt ist wann kein Wind
weht wann keine Sonne weht wie die Lage
etwa in Frankreich ist das heißt es ist
äußerst fraglich ob das überhaupt
funktioniert und es werden damit einfach
weiterhin Potenziale liegen gelassen
bedarf einer Vorlage aber in den Stress
steckbetrieb geht oder nicht aber wie
gesagt das vertiefen wir gleich noch
Herr Kaiser demolieren den dreieinhalb
Monate
Notfallreserve für wirklich den lang
ersehnten Ausstieg die Leistung dieser
im Laufe dieser dreieinhalb Monate wird
sowieso immer weiter zurückgefahren und
neue Kernbrennstäbe braucht es ja auch
nicht
naja ich würde sagen ja denn wir
befinden uns hier in der ganz absurden
Situation dass wir ein
gesellschaftlichen Konsens erzielt
hatten 2012 damals ja unter CDU
fdp-regierung zu sagen 22 ist Schluss
und dieser Konsens wird wenige Monate
vorher von einem grünen
Wirtschaftsminister tatsächlich
aufgekündigt und das in einer Zeit wo
wir täglich besorgt nach chaporica
gucken in das Atomkraftwerk in der
Ukraine wir haben Tschernobyl die
Angriffe gesehen von von Russland wir
wollen unabhängig werden von Russland
und Russland und Kasachstan sind die
Länder die zu 50% Brennstäbe nach Europa
liefern und jetzt als Antwort auf den
Stresstest auf die Technologie von
gestern zu setzen anstatt zu sagen wir
setzen jetzt auf die Technologien auf
die Einsparmöglichkeiten die uns zur
Verfügung stehen die wir für die Zukunft
brauchen ist für uns nicht
nachvollziehbar
da würde ich gerne einhaken weil mich
die Situation saborische auch sehr
besorgt und sie zeigt eben ganz genau
dass wir keine Laufzeitverlängerung
angehen dürfen und das hat Robert habe
auch ausgeschlossen und wir werden
diesen gesellschaftlichen Konsens
beibehalten im Gegensatz zu Union die
schon mal mit dem Ausstieg aus dem
Ausstieg baden gegangen ist darum geht
es genau nicht wollte noch ein Wetzel
ansprechen aber genau das wollen wir
jetzt auch gleich weiter
formulieren Herr wechselt die
verbliebenen AKWs diese drei leisten bei
einem Weiterbetrieb nur ein begrenzten
Beitrag zur Energiesicherheit das sagen
ja selbst die Netzbetreiber lohnt sich
da wirklich dieser Aufwand noch für die
dreieinhalb Monate
nein oder fast nein also im Grunde
bräuchte man eine Laufzeitverlängerung
bei mehrere Jahre das ist auch ein
wirtschaftlich Sinn macht diese
Atomkraftwerke wieder aus der also die
Laufzeit zu verlängern nur dann macht
das wirtschaftlich Sinn und es gibt ja
eine Menge Experten die sagen der
nächste Winter ist nicht der härteste
sondern der übernächste Winter ist hart
und wir haben möglicherweise eine Krise
über drei Jahre und wir stehen jetzt
gerade vor der schlimmsten
Wirtschaftskrise dieses Land je gesehen
hat vorne beispiellosen Energiekrise
deswegen meine ich das war ein Fehler
nur auf drei Monate zu gehen
Laufzeitverlängerung man hätte gleich
aufs mindestens zwei Jahre gehen müssen
und dann hätte es auch was genutzt wäre
aber nicht im steckbetrieb gegangen da
hätte man noch sehr viel mehr neue
Brennstäbe organisieren müssen man lenkt
auch die Sicherheitsüberprüfungen die ja
jetzt nicht mehr stattgefunden machen
müssen Erfahrungen und jetzt daran
anzuschließen und sie gerade gesagt
haben
jetzt können ja das ist gerade auch
angeklungen ja Atomkraftwerke anders als
Gas und Kohlekraft reagieren nicht
einfach innerhalb von Stunden aktiviert
werden das Dauer glaube ich eine Woche
etwa bis sie richtig anlaufen
wäre da nicht wenn man sich schon dafür
entscheidet diese dreieinhalb Monate
dran zu hängen um Spitzenbelastungen und
mögliche Ausfälle zu verhindern davon
vorne herein die Entscheidung für einen
streckbetrieb besser gewesen denn dann
bleiben die ja erstmal am Netz und
müssen nicht im Fall eine Stromausfalls
der sich er möglicherweise auch gar
nicht so lange vorher ankündigt nicht
erst mühsam hochgefahren werden also wir
haben es gehört Atomkraft ist eine
hochrisikotechnologie und ist es
wirklich ein saborischer die Situation
ist sehr ernst die UN sagt es ist
katastrophal dieses AKW befindet sich
mitten im Kriegszustand und in der
Situation müssen wir einfach wieder
sehen dass Atomkraft eine Deutschland
ist eine hochrisikotechnologie und
deswegen ist es nicht gleichwertig zu
entscheiden und deswegen haben wir das
als äußerst Notfall steht jetzt im Raum
dieser Prozess ist also wie das
Monitoring sein muss über die nächsten
Monate wie das Gesetz gestrickt sein
wird das wird im Bundestag entschieden
und sicher wird es nicht so sein dass
man von einem Tag hochfährt und runter
fährt sondern wir werden dann zwischen
im Dezember entscheiden wie ist die Lage
im Januar und das nicht von Tag zu Tag
sondern wird für diesen Monat auch
dieser Betrieb entschieden werden aber
wie gesagt die Einzelheiten werden wir
im parlamentarischen Verfahren
besprechen und auch ein Klima und
energieausschuss da werden wir alle
beteiligt sind
jetzt haben wir das gerade ja schon mit
was verwechsel gesagt hat war ja eher
ein Plädoyer dafür nicht nur den
streckbetrieb aufrecht zu erhalten
dreieinhalb Monate sondern tatsächlich
eine echte Laufzeitverlängerung um zwei
Jahre sagen sie das fordert ja auch der
fdp-parteivorsitzende und
Bundesfinanzminister aber ist das nicht
ein Risiko dass diese letzte
Sicherheitsüberprüfung 2009 war die
sollte eigentlich alle zehn Jahre sein
also eine Art TÜV für ein Atomkraftwerk
hat man jetzt gesagt gut brauchen wir
nicht mehr Ende 22 ist alles Schnee von
gestern ist das nicht doch ein Risiko
jetzt einfach weiterzumachen zum auch
nur diese dreieinhalb Monate dass sie
mich eine Bemerkung von der Weg machen
weil Frau Badem sagt Ausstieg vom
Ausstieg wir haben ja zwei
Grundsatzentscheidungen die beide in
großen Konsens getroffen wurde der
Ausstieg aus der Kernenergie und der
schrittweise Ausstieg aus der Kohle
Verstromung unsere beiden Parteien beide
jeweils mitgestimmt diese
Grundsatzbeschlüsse gelten auch und es
geht jetzt aber darum was wir in der
Krise tun was uns von der Ampel auch von
dem grünen gerade unterscheidet ist sie
machen bei der Kohle des Fass auf setzen
einseitig auf die Kohle berücksichtigen
nicht den CO2-Ausstoß obwohl sie auch
kein Programm haben um die Klima Lücke
zu schließen und wir sind der Meinung
dass jetzt alles in den Topf sollte und
zwar in dem Rahmen den wir die Ampel
selber beschreibt Klaus Müller als Chef
der Bundesnetzagentur sagt es kommen
zwei es können zwei harte Winter kommen
und die Ampel hat mit ihrer Mehrheit die
Bundesregierung ermächtigt Krisen
Notmaßnahmen für die nächsten beiden
Winter zu machen bei der Kohle und wir
sind der Meinung dass dieser Rahmen dass
diese Möglichkeit auch bestehen sollte
übrigens auch bei der Biomasse die ja
weiterhin gedeckelt wird obwohl wir es
im Bundestag beantragt haben diesen
Deckel aufzuheben damit nachhaltige
Bioenergie russisches Gas ersetzen kann
und diesen Rahmen auch bei der
Kernenergie zu ziehen und dann würde ich
mal den Stresstest wirklich kennen wir
kennen ja die Schlussfolgerung des
Ministers aus Stresstest wir kennen die
gegenläufigen Schlussfolgerung der FDP
wir kennen eine Powerpoint-Präsentation
der Übertragungsnetzbetreiber aber wir
kennen nicht den Stresstest insgesamt es
sind ja wochenlange Prüfung
Untersuchungen gewesen das übrigens auch
kein Umgang mit dem Parlament und nicht
mit der Öffentlichkeit dass man das
Schlussfolgerungen präsentiert aber die
faktengrundlage gar nicht veröffentlicht
die muss man aber noch kennen um im
Ausschuss um im Parlament diese
Entscheidungen zu treffen und deshalb
fordern wir die Bundesregierung auf das
ist unverzüglich zu veröffentlichen also
wir sind ja gemeinsam klimaausschuss der
den ganzen Sommer unaufhörlich getagt
hat und es wird laufend informiert aus
dem bmwk aber erstmal ich finde es gut
dass sie nicht veröffentlicht worden
biogasstrom jetzt ansprechen weil das
sind genau die Lösungen die wir brauchen
wo wir wirklich essentiell was beitragen
können
und meine Frage ist welchen Beitrag kann
Atomstrom jetzt wirklich zu Verdrängung
von Gas am besten es ist weniger als ein
Prozent das ist der Grashalm von dem sie
sagen hängt die Lösung der Energiekrise
ab weniger als ein Prozent da müssen sie
ehrlich sein das kann nicht die Lösung
15 Prozent
warum soll es denn richtig sein
Kohlekraftwerke hochzufahren und da
sagen sie das ist ein ganz wesentlicher
Beitrag da bringt sowas aber kann
Energie nicht das passt doch hinten
hier sprechen sie haben als groko 2038
verabschiedet wir wollen den
Kohleausstieg auf 20 30 vorziehen wir
werden an diesem Zeitplan auch
festhalten und wir haben angefangen die
erneuerbaren Energien auszubauen also
ich würde es bitte nochmal auf die dass
wir die Reihenfolge vielleicht einhalten
wir sind aber der Frage macht es Sinn
diese dreieinhalb Monate dran zu hängen
Stresstest oder Notfallreserve ich hatte
ja nach den Sicherheitsüberprüfungen
auch gefragt die jetzt zehn Jahre ausgeb
sind 13 Jahre eigentlich ausgeblieben
sind machen es da diese dreieinhalb
Monate noch aus als Argument gegen den
gegen diesen
vorübergehenden Weiterbetrieb der ja gar
kein Betrieb ist sondern der muss ja
extra wieder angefahren werden für diese
dreieinhalb Monate ist das so
kriegsentscheidend wir haben in den
letzten zehn Jahren erlebt wie
gefährlich diese hochrisiko-technologie
ist wenn was passiert und dafür sind
Sicherheitsüberprüfungen ja elementar
wichtig
die letzte Überprüfung die liegt seit
2009 zurück war auf Kriterien basiert
die vor Fukushima war wo man ja die
Kriterien der internationalen
Überprüfung von Atomkraftwerken noch mal
verschärft hat und verfestigt hat und
man hat eben dem Wissen dass es ein
gesellschaftlichen Konsens gibt das Ende
2022 Schluss ist hat man entschieden
politisch entschieden diese
Sicherheitsüberprüfung seit drei Jahren
auszusetzen und man kann doch nicht Herr
Jung jetzt sagen dass mehrere Jahre
jetzt weiterlaufen lassen soll ohne eine
Sicherheitsüberprüfung zu haben die den
die das Wort auch verdient und da
verstehe ich sie wirklich nicht nach
Fukushima wann sie ja die Partei die
gesagt haben wegen der
hochrisikotechnologie steigen wir aus
Atom aus wir werden die schärfsten
Sicherheitsstandards anwenden und jetzt
wollen sie sagen wegen der ukraine-krise
und der Energieversorgung wo die
Netzbetreiber gesagt haben es gibt auch
andere Lösungen in dem Paket die
getroffen werden können zu sagen wir
wollen mehrere Jahre verlängern ich
glaube das ist kein Weg der nachhaltig
ist und ich glaube der sollte auch nicht
überschritten werden wo ich ganz bei
Ihnen bin dass wir doch jetzt in dieser
Zeit in der wir uns befinden wo wir
einerseits sehen wir sind von den
fossilen importenabhängig wir sind von
den nuklearen Importen abhängig sie
sagen wie kommen wir da schnell raus und
gleichzeitig sagen wir sind mitten in
der Klimakrise da müssen wir auch aus
der Kohle sehr viel schneller raus
deswegen waren wir auch nicht begeistert
dass jetzt Kohlekraftwerke aus der
Reserve genommen werden ich glaube was
es jetzt notwendig macht dass wir sagen
wie können wir den krisenmodus in dem
wir seit drei Jahren sind uns noch mal
angucken sagen wie können wir jetzt in
die Zukunft springen und auf die
Lösungen setzen die uns in die Zukunft
also ich komme auf diese Themen
ich würde nur ganz kurz damit wir dieses
Thema sozusagen
besprochen haben was jetzt in
unmittelbaren den ersten Januar angeht
und diese drei Akademie zur Sicherheit
machen sie hat mich vorher danach
gefragt ob wir waren abgekommen ist ja
nicht richtig dargestellt es finden
fortlaufend Sicherheitsüberprüfungen
statt fortlaufend
fällig ist ja die große wurde ausgesetzt
19 ist finden aber fortlaufend
Sicherheitsüberprüfung statt wo die
Experten in den Kernkraftwerken sind es
muss zu jedem Zeitpunkt die Sicherheit
gewährleistet keine große
überprüfungszeitpunkt gewährleistet sein
das findet jetzt statt das findet bis
Ende des Jahres statt das muss ja auch
nach dem Plan von Habeck im nächsten
Jahr weiter stattfinden und jetzt ist es
die Frage wie schnell könnte man die
ausgesetzte nachholen wäre das bis zum
nächsten Winter beispielsweise möglich
da bitten wir mal die Bundesregierung
auch im Stellungnahme dazu habe kommt am
Mittwoch in den Ausschuss wird dazu
sicherlich am ausführen ich möchte nur
wirklich darauf bestehen es finden
jederzeit Sicherheitsüberprüfungen jetzt
Ende Dezember Anfang Januar eigentlich
auch ausreichend sonst hätte er ja nicht
gesagt dass möglicherweise in den ersten
dreieinhalb Monaten des Jahres 2023 noch
mal Atomstrom produziert wird wenn man
sich die Position von Habeck zu eigen
macht wäre es dann nicht auch noch
besser gewesen das dritte AKW im Emsland
auch in diese
in diese Notfallreserve einzunehmen den
drei Atomkraftwerke selbst wenn der
Anteil am Strommarkt nicht so groß ist
produzieren immer noch mehr als zwei ja
ich mache mir den die Position habe ich
sicherlich nicht zu eigen aber ganz kurz
noch mal diese periodische
sicherheitsüberprüfen kann man im
laufenden Betrieb nachholen das hat auch
die Gesellschaft für Reaktorsicherheit
gesagt also das jetzt zum zum
Killerkriterium aufzublasen ist glaube
ich wirklich verfallen aber man kann es
während des laufenden Betriebs machen
das ist hier spricht jetzt nicht gegen
den gegen die Laufzeitverlängerung
Lingen also aus niedersächsische
Atomkraftwerk wird deshalb nicht
zurückgeholt sozusagen weil die Probleme
sind in Süddeutschland da hat man diese
redest Patch Probleme da braucht man
Kapazität um die Netze nicht zu
überlasten überlasten zu lassen wenn im
Norden der Wind weht und der Windstrom
nach Süden drängt dann dann überlastet
das die letzten Netze deswegen brauchen
wir in Süddeutschland entgegengewicht
das sind die beiden Atomkraftwerke die
da unverzichtbar sind das ist in Lingen
in Norddeutschland natürlich nicht der
Fall deswegen ist es von der reinen
netztechnisch und Sicht ja eigentlich
über also nicht notwendig aber es ist
natürlich notwendig um den Strompreis in
checkt zu halten zum Beispiel ich habe
noch eine Frage an Sie gewechselt das
ist hier schon angesprochen damit wir
das vielleicht auch wenn wir jetzt bevor
wir in die in die konkrete Diskussion
gegen was das jetzt tatsächlich uns in
der nächsten Zeit für uns bedeutet die
Energie Knappheit es ist der Ausstieg
vom Ausstieg das ist ja immer wieder
angesprochen worden dass man quasi den
Atomausstieg rückgängig macht und
Atomstrom wieder in die Situation
versetzt über einen längeren Zeitraum
zum Energie-Mix zu gehören funktioniert
das überhaupt geht das rechtlich geht
das politisch ist das nicht eine nachdem
ja jetzt schon über zehn Jahre dieser
Ausstieg beschlossen ist ist das
überhaupt realistisch und machbar auch
in einer solchen kritischen Situation
wie jetzt über eine dauerhafte
Laufzeitverlängerung ja da muss man das
Atomgesetz ändern es gibt jetzt
inzwischen auch das
energiesicherheitsgesetz das
Reservekraftwerke sozusagen auch die
alten Kohlekraftwerke aus dem Ausschluss
Ausstiegsbeschluss Kohle wieder rausholt
also ich denke gesetzlich ich kann es
fast meinen Federstrich machen denke ich
mal
ist gut also aus ihrer Sicht ist das
kein großes Hindernis wenn der
politische Wille da wäre wäre
dann auch Atomkraftwerke wieder ans Netz
nehmen die schon abgeschaltet waren oder
neu Atomkraftwerken
ehrlich sagen worauf sie jetzt hinaus
wollen und dass sie neue Brennstäbe aus
Russland und sonst woher dann auch dazu
kaufen wollen
überhaupt dass wir hier nur von drei
Atomkraftwerken reden ist schon ein
framing also eigentlich könnten über 6
Atomkraftwerke reden weil auch die
besser als abgeschalteten Atomkraftwerke
haben ihre Betriebserlaubnis
mehr so leicht ausgesetzt aber bis vor
kurzem hätten wir wirklich noch über 6
Atomkraftwerke reden können die mehr
Strom CO2-frei erzeugen als alle
deutschen Solaranlagen zusammen das hat
man natürlich erfolgreich ausgesetzt und
jetzt müssen wir zwangsläufig über die
letzten drei reden aber was bringt uns
das bei den Problemen die wir haben sie
haben Energiepreis angesprochen
es gibt keinen Indiz dafür dass mehr
atomstromnetz die Energiepreis und das
ist das was das Problem für die Leute
ist senken würde wir haben ganz konkrete
Maßnahmen Abschöpfung der übergewinne
und eine strompreisbremse die wir jetzt
verwirklichen werden was sie haben ist
nichts
eine Frage der Knappheit auch für Strom
das im Moment der Strompreis durch die
Decke geht und könnte man oder die Frage
ist kann Atomstrom in einem über einen
gewissen Zeitraum diesen Preis dämpfen
also es gibt ja den Effekt wie sich der
Strompreis bildet und wir aktuell ist es
so dass das teuerste Kraftwerk im Markt
diesen Preis bestimmt das ist das
strommarktdesign und deswegen ist es
einfach falsch und das ist aktuell sind
das Gaskraftwerke und deswegen werden
Atomkraftwerke das ökonstrats
ausgerechnet das wäre eine
Kostendämpfung von 0,5 bis 0,8%
so ist das die Lösung die die Menschen
brauchen ich denke wir brauchen eine
strompreisbremse und wir müssen ganz
konkret und das ist der Ausbau der
erneuerbaren Energien Bayern ist
angesprochen worden als Problem das klar
aber es ist auch ein ganz Deutschland
viel zu tun wir haben ganz Problem ganz
konkret die Vergütung der Solaranlagen
beispielsweise erhöht Solaranlagen auf
dem Dach die Sanierungsprogramme laufen
weiterhin wir bieten ganz konkret
Lösungsmöglichkeiten am es kommt auch
jetzt ins Kabinett die Leistungserhöhung
bei Biogas es wird die spitzenkappung
bei kleinen Solaranlagen wegfallen es
wird eine sonderausschreibung
Photovoltaik geben es wird die
Netzanbindung verbessert bei Wind auf
See das sind alles Sofortmaßnahmen die
wir jetzt bringen die konkret was nutzen
Atomkraft bringt uns überhaupt nichts
bei den aktuellen Themen die Leute
beschäftigen umtreibt aber ist das nicht
das Problem es wird ja immer wieder
gesagt
wir brauchen erneuerbare Energien der
muss ausgebaut werden damit diese ganzen
Probleme über die wir jetzt reden gar
nicht mehr eines Tages existieren aber
eines Tages der Winter kommt viel
schneller der möglich hohe Strombedarf
und mögliche Strom Knappheit kommt viel
schneller als sie ein Windrad aufstellen
können wie soll denn dieser Weg da aus
in einerseits die Struktur von
erneuerbarer Energie den Aufbau zu
forcieren vor allem auch die Netze die
Stromnetze dass der Strom dorthin kommt
wo er hin muss auf der einen Seite und
auf der anderen Seite aber
übergangsweise eine einen Energiemix zur
Verfügung zu stellen damit Strom auch
Wärme im genügendem Ausmaß zur Verfügung
steht wie kommt man aus diesem Dilemma
raus ich glaube wir brauchen einen
Bündel von Maßnahmen nur ich glaube der
Diskurs der gerade geführt wird zu der
veraltenten Technologie Atom sollte viel
mehr geführt werden wie können wir jetzt
sehr schnell Kapazitäten schaffen und
vor allem von Wind in Bayern und in
Baden-Württemberg die kommen aus
Baden-Württemberg sie wissen es auch
Bayern ist der Zustand von von Ausbau
von Wind noch defizitärer was aber
passiert dass gerade Herr Söder in
Bayern jetzt eine at Debatte hochgezogen
hat um abzulenken davon dass die
Windkrafträder fehlt und ich bin ja wir
haben Herrn Habig sehr stark kritisiert
dafür dass er jetzt aus dem Nichts in
wenigen Monaten schwimmende
lng-terminals für Erdgas bauen wird ein
windkra eine Windkraftanlage ist im
Vergleich dazu ja technisch trivial
warum haben wir jetzt nicht eine
offensive dass wir sagen das Potenzial
was wir als loathing fruit haben in
Bayern in Baden-Württemberg wird jetzt
bis zum nächsten Winter ausgebaut das
ist der Teil erneuerbare Energien der
andere Teil ist ja die Frage
Energiesparen lastenmanagement
lastenabwurf da ist eine Verordnung
ausgelaufen die müsste man jetzt wieder
in Kraft treten lassen dass man sagt
welche Unternehmen welche welche Energie
verbrauchen den Einheiten sind bereit
gegen ein entgeltstrom auch einzusparen
in bestimmten Phasen wenn es
lastenmanagement das sagt und wir haben
ja einen mündliches lastenmanagement das
kann man dann planen dass diese
Potenziale voll ausgeschöpft werden und
ich meine die die Szenarien die der
Minister Habeck gestern vorgelegt hat
das ist ja der Worst worst Worst Case wo
wir sagen diese ganzen Grundannahmen die
da drin sind da muss man jetzt erstmal
glaube ich im November Dezember dann
auch gucken das muss ich dann gar nicht
machen bitte wenn sie sagen dass da
sowieso nicht kommen wird oder sehr
unwahrscheinlicherweise kommen wird das
muss ja für Greenpeace dann sein wird ja
sowieso kein großes Thema für uns werden
wir haben schon immer einen
hervorragendes lastenmanagement hier
hier in Deutschland ich war selber in
der kohlekommission da wurde uns das mal
berichtet so wenig Blackouts wie in
Deutschland gibt es ja europaweit gar
nicht also das ist sehr sehr gut und
genau darauf können wir können wir
setzen und dann eben gezielte Maßnahmen
treffen auch bei der Energieeinsparung
und beim lastenmanagement mit anderen
europäischen Ländern darf ich da ganz
kurz äh Jungs die weil es jetzt mehrfach
angesprochen wird ist vor allem die
Energiepolitik der CSU in Bayern haben
in ihre parteifreundete ja nicht ein
rieseneins-nest gelegt ich kann mich
erinnern 2017/ setzen wie damals der
damalige bayerische Ministerpräsident
Horst Seehofer reagiert hat als es um
den Ausbau der Stromnetze von Nord nach
Süd ging da gab es Bürgerinitiativen da
gab es massenweise Proteste auf die
Seite von dieser Proteste hat sich
sofort Seehofer gestellt obwohl diese
Netze ja dringend notwendig waren mit
dem Satz mein Koalitionspartner sind die
Bürger klingt zwar alles ganz nett aber
jetzt kommt eben auf Bayern diese
Situation zu dass es dort wirklich einen
Energie einen Strom Mangel gibt wegen
dieser fehlenden Netze man trifft sich
immer zweimal im Leben war das ein
großer strategischer Fehler der CSU
selbst die Partei von den Ilse Aigner
hat ja gesagt wir hätten haben damals
einfach falsch entschieden also wir
haben in ganz Deutschland in den letzten
Jahren viel erreicht beim Ausbau der
erneuerbar es hätte aber auch schneller
gehen können ich sage auch ganz deutlich
es hätte auch manches schneller gehen
müssen aber sehr von der CSU eigentlich
verhindert worden dieser Ausbau ich
glaube nicht dass man das jetzt so
parteipolitisch sehen können sie haben
die Windkraft angesprochen werden in
Baden-Württemberg seit
Jahren in grünen Ministerpräsidenten wir
haben übrigens keine Abstandsflächen die
dann auch immer als Argument ihre
nachteilung ja und trotzdem geht es
nicht ging es nicht so schnell wie es
gehen sollte namentlich übrigens wegen
dem Artenschutz ja wegen dem Vogelschutz
weil dort Regeln nicht getroffen wurden
jetzt ist da eine Neuregelung gemacht
worden vielleicht geht es dadurch
schneller es ist vieles zu
Beschleunigung gemacht und das
unterstützen wir bei dem Netzausbau
übrigens haben wir auch dem Gesetz der
Bundesregierung der Regierungsmehrheit
zugestimmt nachdem unsere Forderung das
auch das ein Gegenstand öffentliches
Interesse zu beschleunigen werden soll
nachdem das aufgenommen wurde das finden
wir richtig und deshalb haben wir
zugestimmt und da gilt es in dem stimme
ich zu alles zu tun um erneuerbare
Energien auszubauen so schnell wie
möglich Stimme zu wenn sie sagen man
muss mehr bei Einsparung tun wir haben
nach wie vor kein nationalen
Energiesparplan warum lädt eigentlich
nicht Olaf Scholz die Ministerpräsident
mal nicht nur zu Corona sondern auch zu
Energiepolitik ein um ein gemeinsames
Sparplan zu machen wir haben nach wie
vor nicht das lange angekündigte
Programm für freiwillige Einsparung in
der Industrie
Klaus Müller im Mai vorgeschlagen es ist
in der Bundesregierung lang diskutiert
worden ist als im Oktober kommen da sind
über den sommerpotenziale vergebenen das
muss man alles machen aber dann bleibt
der Punkt sie haben die Preise
angesprochen und Preise bilden sich nach
Angebot und Nachfrage wenn es Angebot
größer ist gehen die Preise runter ich
bezweifle die Zahl die sie genannt haben
und deshalb könnte dieser befristete
Weiterbetrieb der drei Kernkraftwerke
eben doch was bringen und es geht auch
im europäische Solidarität nehmen Sie
Frankreich werden mit den Franzosen den
Aachener Vertrag haben uns Ängste
Freundschaft Partnerschaft versprochen
aber mit denen kein Beistandsabkommen
für Energie obwohl die europäische
Verordnung ins deutsche Gesetz genau das
vorgibt und wir haben es nicht weil die
Franzosen aus sich gestellt haben wir
könnten Gas schicken im Winter aber im
Gegenzug bei ihrem Strommangel auf Hilfe
aus Deutschland hoffen und deshalb auch
erwarten dass wir im Gegenzug beide der
handeln und deshalb werden da Chancen
momentan muss jetzt konsequenter
gehandelt werden ja ich muss ja
zustimmen dass die Zahl das Atomkraft
Laufzeitverlängerung den Strompreis nur
um 1% drückt eine tatsächliche falsche
Zahl ist sie wurde von habeg genannt
aber sie stimmt nicht weil sie stand aus
einer Fundamentalanalyse so quasi aus
Zeiten nur noch alles normal war wie ist
denn der Strommarkt heute heute ist das
Strommarkt so dass die Unternehmen die
da tätig sind keine Liquidität mehr
haben um Sicherheitsleistungen zu
hinterlegen sogenannten margin calls das
heißt Strom Handel findet praktisch
derzeit nur rudimentär statt das heißt
ganz kleine Mengen die gerade noch
gehandelt werden haben einen riesigen
Hebel auf den Strompreis und das da
machen vier Gigawatt Atomstrom eine groß
und den großen Hebel aus tatsächlich und
deswegen ist es in dieser 1% definitiv
falsch also selbst fragen Sie
unabhängige Beratungshäuser in nervis
die sagen die kommen auf mehrfache
mehrfach höhere Prozentsätze ich glaube
sie bestreiten nicht dass wir gerade das
merit order-system im Strommarkt haben
das heißt das teuerste Kraftwerk
bestimmt hin reformiert werden soll aber
deswegen muss sie reformiert werden das
teuerste Kraftwerk bestimmt den Preis
und das heißt dass ihre These mit
Atomkraftwerk falsches außer sie
bezweifeln dass wir diese
strommarktdesign haben was und dann
werden sie definitiv auf der Strom
eingehen weil da war wirklich so vieles
dabei was schwierig war also wenn wir
uns Bayern mal anschauen ich bin ja auch
aus Bayern und ich finde es schade dass
man dann immer so dieses Bundesland die
Staatsregierung eher gesagt sich immer
in die Negativschlagzeilen katapultiert
das hat begonnen mit dem Thema billiges
Erdgas man hat kurzfristig auf Preise
geschaut Bayern hat als allererstes bei
Russland eingekauft und man hat nicht
zukunftsgetriebene nachhaltige Politik
gemacht und dieses billige Erdgas war am
Ende sehr teuer weil es uns abhängig und
verwundbar gemacht hat das nächste war
dann das Thema Netzausbau deswegen ist
Bayern jetzt isoliert quasi
wahrscheinlich zukünftige eigene
strompreiszone und dann die Windkraft da
haben wir zum ersten die 10h-regelung
von der Staatsregierung bekommen die
windkraftgenehmigung sind so gut wie auf
Null eingebrochen die Zahlen gibt es und
die sind valide
zwischen zwei Kilometer Abstand
Windkraft zu Wohnbebauung dann hat die
große Koalition noch Gesetz
verabschiedet die den Windkraftausbau
noch vom Bund torpediert haben war für
Bayern relativ egal weil sowieso nichts
mehr ging aber das war dann sozusagen
der doppelte windkraftdeckel und wir
haben das jetzt aufgehoben wir haben in
wenigen Monaten gemacht mehr als die
letzte Koalition in den letzten Jahren
gemacht hat und wir haben das größte
erneuerbaren Energien Ausbaupaket seit
20 Jahren verabschiedet und da geht es
natürlich auch um die Beschleunigung der
Windkraft weil wir wollen wieder zu
sechs Monaten genehmigungszeit und wir
wollen nicht sechs Jahre
genehmigungszeit wir haben es angepackt
sie reden nur sie reden von Scheinlösung
während wir ganz konkret für die
Bürgerinnen und Bürger das Verbessern
bei der Windkraft bringen müssen als
Lösung dieser diese Energiekrise reden
also in der erneuerbaren Energien haben
eine Anteil also Wind und Solar mal
Anteil von 8% am Ende Energieverbrauch
Deutschlands vielleicht fünf Prozent
Primärenergie jetzt zu tun als können
wir mit ein paar Windräder ein bisschen
Solarenergie aus Energiekrise rauskommen
ich glaube dass das Thema dass wir heute
Abend nicht
Stabilität im Strommarkt und deswegen
ist es glaube ich schon wichtig über
erneuerbare Energien im System zu reden
und ich das ist ja genau das Problem
dass wir mit einem fast 50 prozentigen
Anteil im Strombereich von erneuerbaren
Energien jetzt in ein System reinkommen
wo wir im Grunde ein sehr flexibles
Energiesystem haben wo natürlich
Atomkraftwerke auch allein vom vom
System her natürlich mit ihrer nicht
vorhandenen Flexibilität des ein- und
ausschaltens ja gar nicht mehr zeitgemäß
sind das heißt wir sind ja tatsächlich
an einem Sprung in ein neues Zeitalter
und deswegen ist ja unsere Kritik an
Minister Habegger auch so groß dass er
sagt allein mit dem ins Spiel bringen
einer einer Reserve über Atom überhaupt
nicht diesen Sprung macht und so sagt
wir brauchen jetzt den Ausbau von
erneuerbaren Energien der jungen wir als
Umweltorganisation sind ja intensiven
Diskurs wie man Hindernisse abbauen kann
was wir aber auch wissen
gerade die Planungskapazitäten in vielen
Behörden ist gar nicht da an den
Gerichten die Kapazitäten um die Fälle
zu entscheiden sind ich da und ganz
wesentlicher Punkt wo wir hinkommen
müssen dass die Bürgerinnen und Bürger
vor Ort auch ökonomisch profitieren von
den erneuerbaren Energien und da haben
wir jetzt muss ich leider sagen die
letzten zehn Jahre eine Zeit gehabt
wurde es nicht so gut funktioniert hat
und wo wir aber wieder hinkommen müssen
weil sonst wird es nicht funktionieren
und ich glaube das ist unser Punkt auch
wir führen die Debatte Atom der
Vergangenheit und ich glaube wir sollten
die Debatte der Zukunft wie wir beide
gerieben
Debatte vor allen Dingen für den
kommenden Winter führen was passiert da
jetzt in Reden von einem Sprung in die
Zukunft in die Energiezukunft das ist
aber kein kurzer Sprung sondern ein
ziemlich langer wir sind Jahre von einer
Klimaneutralität im Fernsehen es geht
jetzt darum wie kommen wir über diesen
und vielleicht auch noch die nächsten
Winter wenn es diesen Atomstrom nicht
mehr gibt muss wieder mehr Gas verstromt
werden das ist wahnsinnig teuer Robert
habe hat gestern auch auf entsprechende
Nachfrage gesagt er rechnet nicht damit
dass Nord Streams 1 wieder eröffnet wird
und nutzt in zwei sowieso nicht wir
haben mit Frankreich eine Vereinbarung
wir kriegen von dort Gas dafür müssen
wir dort auch Strom hinliefern bei
eigenem Strommangel die Kohle muss
erstmal ran geschafft werden in die
Kraftwerke in die Kohlekraftwerke wir
sehen wie schwer das ist Stichwort
Flüsse die nicht mehr so viele Schiffe
aufnehmen können die viel Kohle
transportieren können das wird ein
logistisches Problem wie muss nicht der
Energiemix in 10 oder 20 Jahren aussehen
wie sieht er in den nächsten sechs
Monaten in dem Winter herrscht bei uns
aus wir müssen
für den nächsten Winter einen ganz klare
einsparverpflichtung auch durchsetzen
bei der Industrie bei den Behörden dass
wir signifikant gerade in den in den
Regionen im Süden vom Stromverbrauch
runterkommen erstreste sagt auch bei den
intensivsten Szenarien es geht um
Stunden also an dem Tage Wochen Monate
sondern es geht um Stunden auf die wir
gucken müssen und ich glaube da müsste
man jetzt anfangen zu sparen ich glaube
dieses Sparen von Gas das läuft ja weil
Gaskraftwerke wird man im Süden brauchen
und um das zu stabilisieren und wir
müssen sparen und was ich vorhin noch
mal sagen wollte deswegen macht jetzt
noch etwas deutlicher das was wir
gezeigt haben oder zeigen wollen bei
fossilen Gas und da schwimmende
terminals in Deutschland aufzubauen
innerhalb von Monaten das brauchen wir
diese Initiative brauchen wir jetzt auch
im Süden Deutschlands für die Windkraft
schneller zu bauen sind als genügend
Windkraft bin immer eine Bemerkung
machen weil das immer vom Süden
gesprochen wird und da haben wir
Sondereffekte die haben übrigens auch
mit der Nachbarschaft zu Frankreich zu
tun aber wir haben ja anders es ist
dargestellt haben vor allem jetzt nicht
ein Problem nur im Süden oder nur in
Bayern oder so wie sie es hier
darstellen wollten sondern wir haben
Herausforderung in ganz Deutschland also
die Frage ist Strompreises ist eine für
ganz Deutschland der Klimaschutz ist für
ganz Deutschland bei Linien als
Begründung dafür dass das dritte
Kernkraftwerk nicht in den Notbetrieb
soll laut dem Plan von Habeck schreibt
es Wirtschaftsministerium ja da könnten
ja ölkraftwerke eintreten also man sitzt
wieder lieber auf die fossilen und
verschärfter mit die Frage des
Klimaschutzes also ich finde wir müssen
es insgesamt betrachten brauchen deshalb
auch insgesamt
Lösungen und erneuerbare sind als
Perspektive absolut notwendig muss
beschleunigt werden mit den Dingen die
sie auch gesagt haben in
Baden-Württemberg wird genau das jetzt
gemacht mehr Personal kürzere Verfahren
die Länder können da viel machen der
Bund kann viel machen wir hätten
übrigens in windkonsens für gut geheißen
alle Länder haben Bereitschaft gezeigt
wird davon habe ich nicht abgeholt er
die Reise gemacht durch die Bundesländer
aber dann quasi als Bundesregierung von
oben das Gesetz ohne Abstimmung mit
allen Beteiligten ich glaube dadurch ist
eine Chance auch tatsächlich vergeben
haben also es stimmt nicht es gibt ein
laufende bundländer Koordinierung zur
Windkraft wo sich angeschaut wird wie
die Bundesländer mit ihren Flächen
Zielen stehen diese Austausch findet
statt aber leider und Bayern ist zum
Beispiel ein großes Flächenland bringen
alle nicht den Beitrag oder bzw bringen
sich selbst um den Beitrag und um den
Gewinn und deswegen musst du das Wind an
Land gesetzt erlassen werden und ich
möchte sagen wenn sie sagen was das
nördliche AKW angeht das wäre eine
politische
Fakten die da dargestellt werden dann
würden sie den
Übertragungsnetzbetreibern Politik
unterstellen
nutzen dringend empfohlen steht da drin
Betreibern erstellt und da ist auch klar
dass es im Norden weniger Problem bei
der Netzstabilität gibt das steht drin
ob es wir müssen schon unterscheiden
muss um Fakten geht und wo es um also
veröffentlichen sie die Fakten des
Stresstestes habe ich vorher schon dazu
aufgerufen zweitens des Ministerium des
grünen ministeriumsack lieber
ölkraftwerk es Kernenergie steht in dem
gestern veröffentlichen Papier drin und
drittens Sie Ihre Frage was kann man
kurzfristig kurzfristig in der Krise tun
da muss man die Deckelung der Biomasse
aufheben sie haben es eher
weitergedeckelt als aufgehoben wir haben
es kritisiert wir haben es beantragt das
zu machen da entstehen auch nicht
zusätzlich Konflikte werden im letzten
Jahr im Unterschied zu diesem Jahr viel
Regen wir haben in den Lagern den Mais
vom letzten Jahr liegen der könnte
unmittelbar genutzt werden für mehr
Strom für Wärme für Biomethan aber
dieser gesetzliche Deckel verhindert das
in dem was gestern
das Ministerium veröffentlichtet
in dem was gestern das Ministerium
veröffentliche steht drin nach
Einschätzung des Ministeriums im
nächsten Winter nicht so eine kritische
Lage deshalb andere Situation werden wir
überprüfen aber dass die Haltung des
Ministeriums weil dann würde ja mehr
Biomasse zur Verfügung stehen hätten sie
es doch vor der Sommerpause auf unseren
Antrag hin gemacht und das in diesem
Winter schon da wird jetzt schon helfen
würde jetzt schon Erleichterung schaffen
eine vertane Chance jetzt das im
September ins Kabinett dann in den
Bundestag es ist richtig wenn es gemacht
wird es wird dir dann angekündigt aber
erstmal wird es abgelehnt und viel Zeit
liegen gelassen also Chancen sind viele
vertan wird es geht ja um die Frage was
jetzt getan werden muss um durch den
Winter zu kommen
wir haben gerade Frau warte mal das
angesprochen es muss jetzt beschleunigt
werden das Verfahren aber machen wir da
nicht die Rechnung ohne den wird es gibt
ja nach wie vor egal wer die
Bundesregierung bildet massive Einwände
von vielen Bürgerinitiativen nicht nur
in Bayern und warten Württemberg wenn es
um die Installation von regenerativer
Energie geht also vor allen Dingen
Windkraft Energie die Risiken
windkrafttreter die überall jetzt
entstehen sollen ist das nicht ein
weiterer Hemmschuh der diesen Ausbau
diesen erwünschten Ausbau regenerativer
Energie verhindert wir hatten ja die
letzten Jahre behindert ein sehr viel
stimmiges aber nicht harmonisches
Konzert in dieser ganzen Energiedebatte
und ich glaube was es braucht eine
Verständigung darauf dass wir jetzt
allein für den Strom bis 2035 auf 100%
erneuerbare Energien setzen
und dann auch eine gesellschaftliche
Aufbruchstimmung erzeugen dass wir sagen
ja wir wollen unabhängig werden von den
fossilen Energieträgern wir haben es
gesehen was wozu das führt für sich von
einem Land wie Russland abhängig zu
machen es gibt aber andere Länder bei
denen ist das jetzt auch nicht wirklich
besser und dann haben wir die Klimakrise
wo wir wissen wir müssen aus den
fossilen Energieträgern raus wenn wir da
eine Stimmung erzeugen auch in der
Bevölkerung dass es ein gemeinsamer
Kraftakt ist diesen Winter müssen wir
gemeinsam sparen wenn jeder 15 bis 20
Prozent spart jeder Industriebetrieb
jeder jede Behörde jeder Haushalt dann
kommen wir über diesen Winter und dann
die Perspektive nach vorne und sagen das
ist der Ausbau der erneuerbaren Energien
die Bürgerinnen und Bürger werden
beteiligt an dem Ausbau der erneuerbaren
Energien und wir haben sogenannte
Vorrangflächen wo wir sagen
da wird raumplanerisch ermittelt wo ist
der geringste Schaden auch für Arten
weil das ist ja die weitere Krise die
wir auch haben aber in diesem
Vorranggebieten dann zu sagen hier kann
beschleunigt ausgebaut werden und dann
gucken wir was für einen guten Mix
zwischen Wind und Sonne wir haben ich
glaube bei der Biomasse müssen wir
aufpassen dass wir nicht zu sehr dann
auch in die Ökosysteme reingeht oder in
die Konkurrenz zur
Nahrungsmittelproduktion ich glaube das
muss man sehr gut ausbalancieren aber
ich glaube dann kommen wir auch in einen
gesellschaftlichen Diskurs rein der
glaube ich dann die wenigen
Bürgerinitiativen die es dann noch gibt
wirklich auch mitnehmen können also
wollen ja viele Bürgermeister und
Bürgermeister ich bin bei unterwegs
sehen diese neue Chance durch frischen
Wind im Bund und sagen ich habe eine
Fläche ich möchte hier Windkraft machen
statt regenbehindert ist immer noch
diese Menschen sind jetzt am Start und
wir haben ja auch die kurzfristigen
Maßnahmen das habe ich ja gerade gesagt
für diesen Winter verabschiedet
kurzfristig die PV nutzen die
Leistungsspitzen nutzen kurzfristig die
Bioenergie nutzen aber wir haben auch
die Mittel- und langfrist Planung im EEG
verabschiedet durch höhere
Vergütungssätze durch einheitliche
Standards zum Beispiel beim Wind beim
Naturschutz wobei das nichts einzige das
Hauptthema ist und vieles mehr also wir
haben diese ganzen Hürden aus dem Weg
geräumt und jetzt brauchen wir doch ein
parteiübergreifende Konsens dass wir
diese Kraftanstrengung angehen und
stattdessen Zetteln sie eine Debatte aus
der Vergangenheit an das hilft wirklich
also
sorry
wir müssten die Industrie ja zum
Energiesparen überreden der Gaspreis ist
mal 10 das um den Faktor 10 geschrieben
der Strompreis ist um den Faktor 15
gestiegen ich glaube man muss keiner
Industrie sagen dass sie jetzt bitte
staatlich anfangen die ziehen eher jetzt
schon ab ins Ausland am Freitag hat
artiller mit halt zwei Stahlhütten dicht
gemacht also zwei stahlbetriebe die ich
gemacht in Deutschland die bauen ab die
gehen weg die muss man nicht sagen fangt
an zu sparen auf die Idee sind ja schon
gekommen und dann jetzt weiterhin zu
behaupten wir könnten mit so einer
Erneuerbaren Offensive hier über über
den nächsten Winter die nächsten zwei
Winter kommen jetzt auch völlig
lächerlich ist noch Peanuts klaren
Energie diese sprechen die findet auch
im Winter überhaupt nicht statt also da
reden wir darüber über Megawatt Zahlen
im kann man alleine an einer Hand
abzählen also dazu behaupten das würde
uns jetzt kurzfristig in den nächsten
drei vier Jahren noch irgendwas retten
finde ich völlig daneben also wir reden
über Atomkraft eigentlich und das sind
ihre langfristigen Pläne verinner ich
frag mich warum eigentlich die letzte
windausschreibung im ersten Mai 17 30
Prozent unterzeichnet war obwohl ja das
von der Ampel-Koalition entfesselt
werden sollte Energiewende und das
osterpaket auf dem Weg gebracht worden
ist und trotzdem bringen kommen ihre
Windkraftanlagen doch nicht Mensch
also ich glaube zum einen schon dass der
Beitrag den die Bioenergie auch
kurzfristig leisten kann ein bisschen
mehr als Peanuts das hat schon erheblich
er hat schon erhebliche Potenzial die
kurzfristig erschlossen werden können
langfristig ist der Weg der Erneuerbaren
richtig es ist Energie die wir in der
Heimat haben die wir hier nutzen müssen
auch als Beitrag zu Unabhängigkeit und
zum Klimaschutz ist richtig es muss
ergänzt werden durch Effizienzmaßnahmen
jetzt kurzfristig was ein Einsparung
möglich ist aber auch ein verlässlichen
Rahmen für energieeffizienter ist viel
Verunsicherung auch verursacht worden
durch das Hin und Her der Ampel bei der
Förderung der Gebäudesanierung gibt es
nach wie vor kein verlässlichen Rahmen
muss dringend nachgearbeitet werden und
drittens die wasserstoffstrategie wir
müssen ja unsere Industrie mit Energie
versorgen wir müssen unbedingt
klimaneutral werden aber wollen dabei
Industrieland bleiben Wertschöpfung hier
erhalten die Wirtschaft am Laufen halten
dazu brauchen wir die
wasserstoffstrategie dazu brauchen wir
vielfältige Partnerschaften das ist auch
eine Antwort auf diese einseitigen
Abhängigkeiten die sich jetzt
als Hypothek erweisen in dieser
Situation die von Russland entstanden
ist die haben wir schon auf den Weg
gebracht die müssen jetzt konsequent
fortgeführt werden die müssen vielfältig
sein mit Kanada mit Australien Staaten
in Afrika mit Staaten in Europa wir
brauchen eine energieunion in brauchen
Sonne und Wind Spanien und anderswo und
das muss konsequent vorangebracht werden
das ist das
ich würde gerne noch eine Frage
loswerden in Sachen Entlastungspaket
damit werden wir uns nämlich morgen in
der Phoenix Runde auch noch befassen die
Grünen haben sie sich ja auch auf Panier
geheftet dass sie durchgesetzt haben
dass die sogenannten zufallsgewinne
abgeschöpft werden die besonders wenig
Aufwendungen haben die Unternehmen
besonders viel verdient dazu gehören ja
auch die Unternehmen der regenerativen
Energie wie viel darf man den eigentlich
abzwacken und abschöpfen damit Sie noch
genügend Geld haben um die erneuerbaren
Energien voranzutreiben das natürlich
eine schwierige Debatte aber alle haben
jetzt mehr Gewinne und aber die gleichen
Kostenrechnungen wie vorher aber ich
glaube dass andere weitaus mehr Gewinne
machen die mineralökonzerne
beispielsweise und wir müssen jetzt in
der EU abstimmen wie wir diese
abschöpfungssteuer oder Abgabe bringen
können und wenn das nicht klappt müssen
wir schnell national handeln
erneuerbaren Energieträger gleich mit ab
bei dieser Zufall
kontraproduktiv die frustrien haben uns
in die Krise geführt die Erneuerbaren
werden uns rausführen und wir haben
bereits 50% erneuerbare deswegen hier
von dem groben Zukunftsvision zu reden
ist falsch das ist bereits Realität gut
das Thema möglicherweise dann ohne
Atomstrom je nachdem wie es weitergeht
wird uns erhalten bleibt nämlich die
Frage wie wir über die Energieknappheit
in den nächsten Jahren wegkommen ich
bedanke mich bei Lisa bartum bei Andreas
Jung bei Daniel Wetzel und bei Martin
Kaiser liebe Zuschauer ich habe gerade
schon angekündigt morgen in der Phönix
Runde mit voller Wucht das neue
Entlastungspaket
weiteres und aktuelles in Phoenix der
Tag mit Thomas Bade darin unter anderem
die Antrittsrede der neuen britischen
Premierministerin List brass die heute
ihr Amt angetreten hat bleiben Sie bei
uns
[Gelächter]